even before embracing islam i've always
had this desire to write a book
i don't know why i always had this
desire to write a book
and i said one day i'm going to write a
book and subhanallah
when i became muslim i would say after
the first
two years of islam i said i have to
write a book
to help people like myself
you know and this is like quite some
time ago that i made this decision
to help people like myself or new
muslims to
understand the struggles that a new
muslim goes through to help them to
basically
not go through the same problems that
i've gone through or make the same
mistakes that i have
that was one of the intentions of the
book and the second
was to help the community the existing
muslim community
to basically know how to deal with new
muslims to understand the struggles
that new muslims go through especially
in the in the west
[Music]
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims you are
joined with
only two out of the three fire myself
and angel but today we got gabriel
brother gabriel to cover for rami salaam
alaikum
so how's it going today alhamdulillah
and everything is good mashallah early
morning in malaysia
okay okay nothing to complain right
handel
as we always say if you if you have time
to complain you have too much free time
that's right man so today i heard uh
there's uh there's a rumor
around the street that we got a new book
right journal of a new muslims
yes this is something i've been working
on for quite some time
subhanallah remember even before
embracing islam i've always had this
desire to write a book i'm horrible at
writing by the way that's like one of my
problems as i went through my schooling
as a child teachers always complain
about my
the eligibility of my writing like
handwriting
and the way i would write i think also
that i've been exposed to quite a few
different languages it was difficult for
me to
get the grammar correct and all that you
know so i would like
kind of mess it up but i don't know why
i always had this desire to write a book
and i said one day i'm going to write a
book and subhanallah
when i became muslim i would say after
the first two years of islam i said i
have to write a book
to help people like myself
you know and this is like quite some
time ago that i made this decision
to help people like myself or new
muslims to
understand the struggles that a new
muslim goes through to help them to
basically not go through the same
problems that i've gone through or make
the same mistakes that i have
that was one of the intentions of the
book and the second
was to help the community the existing
muslim community
to basically know how to deal with new
muslims to understand the struggles
that new muslims go through especially
in the in the west all right there's a
lot of communities muslim communities in
the west
they have still quite a strong culture
and they sometimes don't understand
where an american or canadian or
whatever
new muslim comes from or what are the
challenges that they go through so
basically it's
yeah like two parts so one for the new
muslims to help them with their problems
and the second one for the existing
muslim committee to know how to deal
with
the new muslims and to understanding
sometimes they judge they jump to
conclusions without really
knowing the background or the struggles
that they're coming through
so that's what i hope to do with this
book to to help so i really
pray that more new muslims read it
and more community leaders and
masjid activists who have new muslim
programs or who deal with converts
you know go to their masjids to become
muslim
know how to deal with them inshallah so
yeah alhamdulillah that's pretty much
the
the background behind the book
i can say for myself i'm definitely
getting it because i want to know more
about how to deal with new muslims
i think i was going to say angel's going
to get it because he's a new muslim
himself
but i think it's been a couple months
man i don't consider you a new muslim
anymore
right i'm definitely a new muslim still
definitely muslim april how do you
distinguish between a new muslim like a
new weaver and
to when they're no longer considered a
new muslim okay
that is a good very good question i
don't think there's like a cut-off point
in terms of time because everyone deals
with it differently
and enters into the faith differently
but allah tells us in the quran
he says all you believe enter in the
faith
fully right so basically as some of them
say like accept everything right so i
think this is the
cutoff point it could be two years into
islam it could be five years into islam
it all depends the amount of effort a
person puts
to be able to internalize the concepts
and the understanding of islam so
how much quran are you willing to learn
understanding implementation of course
because someone might be just
theoretical and say yeah i understand
everything about islam but like
it doesn't do too much right so these
are all
important points so once you've kind of
entered into islam and have
embraced islam uh you know
positively and fully i think
then you can say i'm not no longer a new
muslim for me i would say it took me
about five years
okay i would say it took me about five
years
to say okay i'm not really a new muslim
anymore
some people it takes them longer some
people subhanallah
throughout you know after 20 years
they're still
they still consider themselves a new
muslim and they still haven't
submerged themselves into the faith
fully so it's hard to say but out you
know so the the
new muslim has to put quite a lot of
effort
to basically become
a muslim now he's going to be a little
bit different
and we see this throughout the history
of islam that there's different cultures
that you know entered islam and they've
adjusted
some of their cultural practices
to be in line with islam and some
they've left because they're totally out
of line in islam
and some were kept because there was
nothing wrong or there was nothing
against islam
islam doesn't like wipe out your culture
as some people might think
okay if i become muslim now i have to be
pakistani or indian or
this or arab or that not necessarily
does that mean that some
these cultures don't have good elements
masha'allah some people
adopt the a certain culture for example
they hang around with arabs or with you
know with desi people
from the subcontinent and they love
their culture and they adopt it like
they start wearing their clothes
and there's nothing wrong with if hey if
he feels like happy about it
you know whatever man like do whatever
you feel that you are happy with and it
fits you you know
i remember meeting a a pakistani sister
as part of one of our social projects
and she was married to
i'm sorry she was a mexican she was
mexican and she married a pakistani
brother you know
but you couldn't tell like she was
speaking fluent urdu and you know all
that and i was like my god you know
subhanallah
and she was like proper pakistan you
know but she was mexican you know what i
mean
and it was quite interesting but she
just loved pakistan and loved
urdu and loved you know these things so
i was like cool
whatever you know whatever floats your
boat if you're happy but if you want to
obviously do the um the islamic
practices
as well as have your culture as long as
they don't conflict
you know bismillah right so
alhamdulillah i think
yeah this is this is basically one of
the things that have to be considered
when defining a
new muslim versus a muslim only
and i do believe that the ummah is very
varied you know has a lot of mashallah
different um
shades of different people and that's
what makes it beautiful and that's what
it was at the time of the process in him
as well
he had salman and farsi he had suhai
barumi
so she was from persia
and so hey barumi was from the romans
from right from the roman empire and you
had bilal habeshi
who was from africa and others from
different tribes and different places
so it was not one homogeneous
you know kind of ummah it was very
heterogeneous
and but they're all muslims and they all
had their
impact and their contributions uh to the
ummah subhanallah like
he was the one who was at the gates
during the khalifa of omar khattab
at the gates of persia telling them you
guys have you know pretty much three
options what do you want to choose right
he's like i'm from you guys but he's
like i feel
he said like i feel bad for you but like
this is the truth you know what i mean
so he's like advising them right
speaking to them in their language
uh so subhanallah you know it's it's
it's amazing right this this
is beautiful like the the variety
so yeah i mean for me it took me five
years i would say to really get
over the initial stages and difficulties
of being
a new muslim and after that it became
much much easier so
this is my theory i think if you pass
the five-year mark
while doing and putting your effort that
you have to do
then i believe inshallah from there on
it's all good alhamdulillah
i think at one point you had told us how
long you were muslim
for how long has it been uh it's been
18 years now almost yeah
so 18 years
and um you said you wanted to write this
book now
for a long time even before you were
muslim you said you wanted to write a
book
so how long did it actually take you to
write this book and like when did you
make that decision like ah okay it's
time like i feel like what i've been
through
is something that can potentially help
okay so i think as i said about two
years into islam i said i need to write
i started writing
i think about two years three years into
islam
so i think 2006 or seven
um i started i was still writing
and going through the process i got some
people to help me i don't know if you
guys remember if you know
brother sajid
he was the first one a second one i
think to edit my book
and that time he was just he just
entered islam you know
he just became a muslim uh you know
masha after that he went to medina
and mashallah's got his great channel
now doing a lot of good work
but he was the that i think his name was
rob his name was robert
and i even have the the initial copy
that has
edited by rob liphim you know it's quite
cool and
i didn't actually lost touch with him
for a long time he just
recently we reconnected about a year ago
but um so it took me quite some time to
write it
and i think it was an ongoing process
because that's why i
read you know remastered it or whatever
what was the term you used uh
remastered it's a remastered copy
and i really put more time into it 2019
2020 you know i said you know it's a
lockdown let me just focus on finishing
this i've been
putting it off but also i think it was
so important to do it now
after you know 17 18 years of being a
muslim
because i've had so much experience
working with new muslims
within the social
organization social organizations of
masajid and communities around the world
i've dealt with so many theological
issues and social issues within these
communities
and running some of these new muslim
support projects
that it really gave me a better insight
not only into my own
experience but into others and to
connect to their experiences to find
patterns
if that makes sense so it was like
introspective but als also analytical
of others and i think that was important
because i didn't want it to be just
subjective just to my experience and
indeed i did find
and i'm sure you've hear this a lot that
a lot of the new muslim stories
kind of have the same tune or there's a
lot of the same
type of you know stories that come
together
so doing this in 2020
it made a lot of sense because i could
look back
i could really analyze everything that
i've gone through and others have gone
through
my experience and then talked to
different people and this okay this
these are some of the things that you
muslims
go through in general and these are
maybe some of the things that i've gone
through just
as exceptions but in indeed
it was a great i think it was just the
perfect timing
and i had some help like i invested some
money in getting it edited properly
by a new muslim sister herself masha
okay who understood basically what i
wanted to do as well and that really
helped a lot because you know
she is a new muslim she's been muslim
for quite some time and she lives in
i think in morocco or something she's
american
and so there's a lot of connection there
in terms of understanding
what i'm trying to what the spirit of
the book right and she really did an
amazing
job and
yeah alhamdulillah i mean also i've had
a designer to kind of arrange the book
and then we decided to put an e format
obviously because
with kovi right now shipping things and
whatnot it's a big mess i said you know
what
i think this is my answer bismillah
let's just do an e
book easily accessible and i one of the
things that i've done to the book
that was quite different was to put in a
lot of pictures
like i think every page has a personal
picture in it
that has a caption that tells a story or
is linked to whatever i'm talking about
from the time when i was a child
family friends people who gave me
shahada i mean the
brother gave me shahada people supported
me early into my slam
all these pictures are are there so
there's kind of like a
progression into my islam with pictures
that have a story behind it so i think
it makes it very personal
and i thought a lot about it but
subhanallah being an educator myself
and having been a teacher for a long
time and a school principal
and dealing with curriculum the most
important thing
when telling a story is the connection
you know being able to connect with
people and i believe
that's where the the subjectivity does
play an important role
because people want to know who you are
and what's your story
in this world and how did you make sense
of things in this life
so that was something that really i
think benefited
those who read it and those who gave me
feedback on it
so do you think uh or not do you think
but any of the people that are about to
embark in reading this book are they
going to catch any selfies of you in
this book
yeah yeah there's there's quite a few
selfies early in my
jahilia before islam as well as early
into islam
so there's quite a lot of selfies here
alhamdulillah i usually don't open up
about my family too much on
social media but in this book i did
write a few things
like about my brother that passed away
about my family my kids stuff like that
i try to be very careful that on social
media usually
so i don't for those who follow me i
don't really post too much on that
but in this book i did show a little bit
because people said look man we don't
know anything about you like why is so
secret i'm like there's a reason for
that uh
but i've kind of you know put a few
things there about you know my mom who
became muslim
as well right she became muslim like two
years after me so she's been muslim for
about 15 years right
and you know some of those struggles and
alhamdulillah you know
yeah so it you're essentially feeding
them scraps i like that
uh but what i'm gonna say is uh
subhanallah i think it is the most
perfect time
for your book to actually be coming out
because
i don't know if it's just me but i feel
like
we're at a pivotal point where a lot of
people have been
uh reverting to islam i mean maybe it's
the covid
maybe it's the lockdown maybe it's the
times that we're in
i don't know what it is but i really do
think that it's a pivotal point
yeah yeah no doubt man i was reading a
book last night
um the dilemma of the muslim
psychologist
and one of the points that the brother
was making into
in the book was the failure of the
west the materialistic western
philosophy
to feed the soul and he was saying that
and backing it up that
[Music]
contemporary psychology as and
philosophy of the western thought has
failed to basically give humans a
purpose
because materialistic
philosophy doesn't give you a purpose
people have achieved materialism and
then they realize that okay i'm not
happy
and he said the i think he was quoting
nietzsche you know it was quite
interesting i don't i mean i don't agree
with nietzsche and many things he's
quite uh a weird philosopher and has a
lot of antis
you know anti faith but he says that
give a man
a purpose or if and he can deal with any
what you know so and i think that's a
very profound statement if you ha
if you have a purpose in life
like you can deal with anything
you can see that through from uh
the people in palestine right now who
are being bombed
and killed and they're still going you
know why they're going is because they
believe in allah
that's what makes them go because
for them this world is materialistic or
materialism is just
temporary and they have a higher purpose
their why is
the most important thing that's why they
can deal with
all these problems and the same when you
look into the muslim world i think there
was an article recently
about the war in yemen and the guy
was a non-muslim and he said something
like god
lives in yemen because he said every
person i interviewed were kind like
alhamdulillah
praise be to god you know thanks be to
god every time and like
and he's depressed he said i'm sitting
around here looking at
rubble and destroyed buildings and dead
people and they're saying
you know praise be to god and thank god
and all these things right you know how
the muslims say right
alhamdulillah inshallah masha'allah
we're always like
positive with that subhanallah so
i think the world as you said angel
right now
especially the western world is looking
for a purpose
now this is where we come in either with
your podcast you know the three muslims
and whatever we do i know you got your
youtube and you're saying a lot of cool
things there
like this is our
chance to reach out to people because
the one thing that islam
gives no doubt it starts with that
is a purpose in life that's the most
beautiful thing is like
no matter when when you have iman in
your heart and we are you gonna have a
lot of issues and problems
it's not problems are not going to go
away look at the palestinians they're
believers
why are they being bombed you know
people can say what's going on i thought
if you're a believer now things are
going to be good no it's not like that
it's not like that sometimes the
stronger the faith the bigger the test
and we look at that
the prophets that you know past old
testament prophets
quran prophets throughout the ages these
were the people that have gone through
the bigger tests the biggest test
right because that's the way it is these
this
these tough times they make strong men
you know
so the world is looking i think we have
the solution
i believe we have the solution
to rid the world of
anxiety depression and even more so lack
of purpose
lack of purpose now
it reminds me of the verse in the quran
do you think that just because you say
you believe
that you're not going to be tested that
is a perfect
perfect perfect test there man
so so gabriel i have a question for you
and this is for myself as well but like
i have a feeling that a lot of
viewers or a lot of people who are on
the fence i'm getting this book of yours
um what's something
that really hit home for you as a beaver
you know like when you
were coming into islam and you were
learning like you said it took
for you it took you about five years
before you said okay
i'm no longer a new muslim i feel like
i'm pretty grounded in my faith so
what is something that really stood out
to you as a reaver
that you could maybe share here
for the people that are watching this
episode
so that they can have a little bit of
insight even more so as to what this
book is going to bring them okay
two things inshallah
i talk about my spiritual experience
[Music]
in entering islam and i describe
in this book a dream that i had
and i was a student of psychology at
that time when i became muslim
and one of the things that really really
fascinated me
and for those who understand the
definition of psychology
is is really the study of the
of the psych and that is the spirit
actually which
modern psychology doesn't really address
but one of the things that
fascinated me within psychology was
dream theories you know and
i remember the dream that i had that
pushed me actually to
finally embrace islam of course the
personal experience and it's subjective
but
for me it was like it was a catalyst
because i was going through so much
intellectual stimulation and research at
that time
to understand what is islam and why
islam is the truth but i think i needed
that
spiritual push and it came through that
dream
so that's one thing you can read about
and the second part is
is the learning process in islam
and i was blessed to be able to i think
it was just a gift from allah
that someone took me under their wing at
the beginning
a you know a scholar who was able to
guide me and to teach
me not just like what to think or
what to learn but also how to what's the
islamic way of thinking and looking at
the world
and connecting to the verses of the
quran
and i remember we used to start start
our study circle just by one verse of
the quran or a couple verses quran just
really
getting deep into it and connecting and
that was probably the most
the most powerful thing to connect to
real life situations
and to to your life and whatnot so
these were a huge things for me that
helped me
early into my islam to stay in islam to
make the transition between being a new
muslim to
a you know a muslim and
moving on to help others because that
was the
panel within the first few years i was
just
you know allah just pushed me into that
field
to support new muslims and
even existing muslims in council and
you know i was one of the the early
social workers in our community
so subhanallah that was like very very
early and fresh myself i was still
struggling myself but
i don't know subhanallah allah just
opened up that opportunity
the community was looking at me saying
you're a new muslim you've had
experience with these things
you do it and i was like i looked around
there's no one else doing it and i said
all right bismillah let's jump you know
so
hamdi i don't regret it it was just it
was part of
my development and being who i am today
and have i not had those experiences
i just i don't think i would have been
here today
[Music]
i got two things to say one salaam
alaikum
will have and number two
simply put we know all guidance is from
allah alone but
if all other variables are the same if
you got two people
one they don't read your book and their
new muslim
second one they do read your book what
is the difference between them
assuming all other variables are the
same
right i think for those who read my book
i give some practical
solutions on how to deal with some of
the problems of doubts for example
which are inevitable as the new muslim
no
doubt you will have doubts
[Laughter]
it's just the way it is bro it's like
it's part of
of the process because you have
you know is the kama or
thibaut or consistency and lack of doubt
comes from knowledge and a new muslim
doesn't really have all that knowledge
when he enters islam
there's going to be a bunch of questions
plus
satan is like on your head knocking you
day and night because he's very upset
that you've actually chosen islam
there's going to be a lot of whispers
and thoughts that are going to come to
you and you're going to have thoughts
about islam that are very negative you
can even
sometimes you cannot even talk to
someone and that is one of the issues
that i address in my books is that
my experience opening up to some of the
scholars or some of the
and how they reacted to me which i think
was very negative
because they just didn't understand what
i was coming from you know
and it was the same as the priest did
when i was a you know when i was in
catholic school
in high school right when i had a
question about the trinity and they're
just like no you cannot ask these
questions these are from
the devil and all that you know and i
didn't question i was
asking a question there's a difference
you know between
questioning and asking a question asking
questions about i just want to know
you want to understand you're seeking
truth sincerely
so i think if they read my book i
address some of these
critical issues that a lot of people try
to put under the carpet because they
don't they feel it's embarrassing you
know it's like oh an issue of doubt or
you don't believe in islam oh what are
you are non-muslim oh
this and that issues of identity
culture seeking knowledge
traveling things that a lot of numerous
marriage okay a lot of that is there
a lot of the things that new muslims
will encounter within the first
few years of their islam so i think by
telling my story and giving
some of the practical tips that i do it
will save them
a lot of headache you know because again
remember it's not just my experience
it's connected to a lot of other
new muslims experience so it's like okay
it's like a theory that you can
practice and hopefully would save you
some time and save you some
depression some anxiety that i've had
going through these things and dealing
with these things
so it's like a you know alhamdulillah a
good shortcut inshallah
that will help you to maybe accelerate
your
you know transition from new muslim to
muslim
so you can help the community and the
world and give them your best
earlier and faster inshallah
just listen to all this like it's
instantly relatable and i'm not just
saying it like
as you're saying it i'm just like ah
yeah i could see that
like especially when you said that uh
going up to a shake
and then saying something and just
feeling like you can't really go to
anyone because they're not really
understanding where you're coming from
i do feel that 100 i do feel that
so a question that i have is you said
that
you personally had
you had someone that took you under
their wing
do you feel like that's something that's
very important
for reverts yeah no doubt no doubt
uh first and foremost because it's a
prophetic approach
to education that's exactly what the
prophet salallahu
as soon as anyone entered islam and not
just that he established the system
so he would teach the
companions and then those once they were
strong enough then they would start
teaching
it became a system even when the great
arabia entered islam
he would always send a sahaba
a companion to move and to live with
those people
like literally they would just totally
move there to iraq
to syria wherever they were where is
this the
the empire islamic empire would spread
he would always send
someone who was grounded in the faith
who understood the challenges
to basically be with the people and
guide them and you know nurture them
and so on and it was a nurturing process
it was not just the
educational process there was it was a
360 degree
system mashaallah so it is definitely a
prophetic
process that i think it's not applied
today
and i've worked with many masajid
or mosques in canada usa
middle east all over the world the only
place where i've seen till today we're
struggling with this
till today new muslim support services
are quite weak
throughout canada and i'm not sure if
you guys know in toronto coach zubair
maybe that's someone i would recommend
you guys do a little podcast with
uh he's he's in toronto and he works
with new muslims and he can definitely
tell you
how things are in toronto on the ground
there with new muslims
but we're still way way
way way way you know like behind what
we're supposed to be when it comes to
new muslim support groups
and how to find a correct system which
is
based on prophetic tradition i would say
that takes in consideration the culture
everything that happens
who these people are and takes and under
their wing
and helps them and then puts them back
out in society to
help others that's the whole point one
of them as my teacher was saying he said
the da'wah
or this faith is like this movement
is like a hospital you know you kind of
treat people
and then you release them you discharge
them and let them go back in society and
start doing their thing
it's not a hotel where people check in
and out and do whatever they want
it's not a jail where you lock people
it's not you know it's
it's gotta that's what he compared to he
says like a hospital you know we heal
people
spiritually we support them morally
physically whatever
socially and then boom once they're
ready
you know let them be out there and start
more small projects like this and
help other people so it's critical to
have
someone to take you under their wing and
support you and
guide you someone who understand who has
wisdom not only knowledge
because if you look through the quran
allah
he blames people who have knowledge but
no wisdom
and actually the comparison that's given
is quite a
harsh comparison as donkeys who have
books on their back
right because it's just carrying weight
of knowledge but no correct application
or wisdom
of that knowledge so i think that is key
inshallah
do you think that even born muslims
should also
have someone take them under their wing
because i mean there's a lot of born
muslims that uh
they're pretty much on reverse status
that's a good point i like that river
status
yeah i believe so man because the only
difference is
i think with the people who are born
into islam
into muslim families anymore we're all
born muslims
is the nurturing that takes place that
kind of gets internalized so it's kind
of in their identity
um yes people were born into muslim
families do leave islam
do apostate and do become even you know
sometimes
worse than non-muslims but in general
i think those who have been raised as
muslims
still have that identity like i'm a
muslim no matter what you know what i
mean even if i'm
a bad person or i do weird things
i'm still a muslim but indeed they do
need that support because this prophetic
approach is for everyone not just new
muslims
indeed indeed the sahaba of the prophet
salallahu
pretty much all of them except for a few
they were born and still
lived with the process and as children
and as young men
but most of the big sahabas that we know
they're all converts
all of them are reverts or converts abu
bakr roma rothman
ali all of them are riverts
and that's that's why i think it's very
important to understand the early lives
of the sahaba when dealing with
new muslims and i think many people
don't know how to make that connection
so yeah just to answer your question i
think both reverts as well as
born muslims into muslim families they
all need that wing to protect them
because it is a prophetic approach that
covers everyone inshallah
masha'allah so
are you taking anyone under your wing
anytime soon
yes alhamdulillah i have a few people
alhamdulillah
under my wing and myself yeah
we are always trying to to have a system
to help people
to uh to continue their journeys
uh through islam and to become people
who will take people under their wing
to nurture people who are going to take
people under their wing that's that's
what we're trying to do inshallah
inshallah well i think that was
beautiful
i think if fayette and rami don't have
anything to ask i think the only
question to ask is where can we get the
book
okay inshallah so in all my videos or my
post
i link the book the
site to purchase the book you can see
the
the uh you know just the description of
the book the pictures
some samples and then you can just order
it
and alhamdulillah all the people whoever
orders it
basically all the money goes to
supporting and
creating and generating more tao
inshallah more invitations to islam to
others more videos more
more work so alhamdulillah it's
definitely a great investment
inshallah inshallah
where did you first invest in your
aquarium
yeah alhamdulillah and
if i remember correctly i i i think i
read this somewhere
it's starting to get kind of dark in
here so i'll turn
light on but um
[Music]
oh i don't know if it was uh the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that said
this or it was just
something that's i guess encouraged
but like the the best things that you
can do in this life
and i think one of them was like leave
something that will
continue on after you that will continue
to help you
great yeah that is a beautifully said it
is hadith as you correctly say
the prophet sallam said that it's like
beneficial knowledge it is a sadaqa or
perpetual
you know benefit that will be even after
you're gone and one of them is leaving
beneficial knowledge for people so
people can benefit from
books videos podcasts whatever
you know can be afterward gone michelle
all these things will still be
there you know available for people
people make dua for us you know people
will
you know benefit from us and it it's
like the bank account india
keeps increasing inshallah just from
from these things
all right that was deep there was some
deep silence there
[Music]
i was looking at romney the entire time
i don't know i thought robert was going
to say something he looked like he was
going to say something like that
bro i'm going forward a little bit
actually look i was going to say
something
i'm like dead right what's on my mind
what's up um
on hell first river and we used to like
episode one two like the ogs right
this man could not sit down for more
than five minutes pacing around the room
what reminded me of that was those two
little things hanging down from his fan
and that was always his view he was just
walking around
but i haven't seen him do that a lot
like recently
that's because i have it on the tripod
right now
but do you still feel that instinct to
like go walk around pace around
but you're controlling it i'm in control
well i'm doing a horrible job of
controlling it but
i'm trying it's like
do any of you have adhd yes sir
so you okay you guys understand romney i
think you have it
i use this thing it's right here yeah
yeah yeah so
i'm either like messing around with like
my uh my jogger is like lace thing
or i'm just like i'm grabbing something
and if i'm not grabbing anything
i'm not moving like my head is just like
all over the place and i'm really not
paying attention
you gotta fidget i know i i use my legs
i you cannot see it right now but
they're moving like this
yeah yeah yeah and do the same
and do the same but this thing helps me
a lot though like if i'm tired or if i'm
really like reading or doing something
i'll just be snapping see you reminded
me like
i used to when i first started this uh
the whole nofap thing
when i had an issue i had a rubber band
on my wrist and anytime that i would
feel like
you know going back i would just snap
myself really hard
it didn't work but it's nice for like a
fidgeting thing though i'll be honest
yeah fidgeting is good yeah it's good
yeah yeah what y'all saying
yeah let's end this one it's been
beautiful um
we're going to leave a link in the
description box down below where you
guys can get
this man's book you guys can read it
insha'allah it'll help you whether
you're a reba or
not i know i'm going to read it fire's
going to read it
and romney has to read it now
bro and if you like it
you know send the link as well to
someone else so they can get it that
would benefit inshaallah
the blessings
all right end it up bro
all right pardon me for my absence for
most the uh the episode
but uh i know these guys held it down
masha allah so everybody watching
uh remember to share this with a friend
in sha allah
remember to publicize this book and
comment to help promote our videos on
youtube
it really does make a difference and if
you want to continue to support us
then consider becoming a member of our
patreon the lowest tier
being five dollars a month with that
being said allah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]